Ласкаво просимо до програми Європа У
фокусі раді що ви приєднались до нас ви
можете думати що рабство залишилось у
минулому але мільйони людей по всьому
світу знаходяться у пасті так званого
сучасного рабства від проституції до
підневольної праці людей досі експлуатуй
і в Іспанії ви можете знайти цих
сучасних рабів які працюють хатніми
робітниками їхні права не поважають Вони
часто змушені працювати до пізньої ночі
а їхнє житло це зазвичай крихітна
кімнатка у підвалі Інтерни так називають
цих працівників в Іспанії Вони живуть
під одним дахом зі своїми роботодавцями
як хатні помічники часто вони не мають
жодних документів не мають посвідки на
проживання і Це робить їх ще більш
вразливими іспанський уряд прийняв більш
суворі закони
Але незважаючи на це такі люди як делія
і далі стають жертвами зловживань вона
інтерна і у неї дуже важка робота
6 днів на тиждень 16 годин на день делія
зняла для нас на мобільний телефон свій
робочий день у цій квартирі у Мадриді в
Іспанії вона займається домашнім
господарством і доглядає за дітьми тут
вона і спить Але 57-річна жінка не хоче
показувати нам свою кімнату Це її єдиний
шматочок приватного життя
мене поселили в підвальній кімнаті два
на три метри
[музика]
У мене немає вікна це принизливо
сумно так жити
і цілодобово дбаєш про все що є в
квартирі робиш усе можливе але все одно
опиняєшся у такій ситуації
їх називають інтернами тому що вони
живуть там де працюють Зазвичай вони з
латинської америки або Філіппін Вони
купують продукти доглядають за дітьми
дбають про людей похилого віку як тут у
престижних районах Мадрида ви робите все
готуйте їжу прибираєте ми працюємо 24
години на добу
та й починає ще 6:30
і закінчує що дев'ятій вечора
Карла хірурн очолює асоціацію хатніх
робітниць але вона не цурається
прибирання у минулому жінка теж
працювала інтертерною тепер разом зі
своєю асоціацією вона відстоює права
працівників адже Багато з них не
отримують за свою роботу навіть
встановленою мінімальної зарплати
180 євро на місяць мігрантів Без права
на проживання часто безсоромно
експлуатують
вони не платять нам законного мінімуму
ваші права топчуть ногами тільки тому що
ви не маєте документів а потім коли ви
скаржитеся роботодавець каже Чому я маю
платити вам по закону коли у вас навіть
немає документів
делія часто приходить до асоціації 17
років тому вона приїхала до Іспанії з
Парагваю щоб заробити гроші для своєї
родини
найбільший тягар для неї - це розлука з
дітьми її синові на той час було 10
років а доньці 15
я залишила своїх дітей у Парагваї і
тепер я тут заради чужих дітей
я багато чого пропустила весілля доньки
народження чотирьох онуків смерть батька
усе те що тримає сім'ю разом
делія отримує допомогу від психолога
асоціації
Анна комарго вважає що такі екстремальні
умови життя Інтернів небезпечні це може
призвести до розчарування і депресії
навіть до втрати власної ідентичності
між особистими робочим життям розмиті
ваша приватне життя і особистий розвиток
визначають інші
Влада хочу покласти край цієї
нестабільній ситуації вона запровадила
контракти з мінімальними періодами
відпочинку новий указ передбачає виплату
допомоги по безробіттю хатнім
працівникам але в реальності хатню працю
важко контролювати
роботодавець не зобов'язаний впускати
інспекторів до себе додому під час
перевірки вони можуть посилатися на своє
право на недоторканність приватного
життя
розповідає Що все своє життя мала хатню
робітницю але тепер вони працюють за
контрактом і отримують соціальне
забезпечення вона вважає що життя
інтерна має свої переваги адже за її
словами у них мало витрат
їм не потрібно платити за оренду житла
їжу електрику воду пральну машину
усе це безкоштовно
тому що вони живуть у цьому будинку Вони
можуть заощаджувати ці гроші для себе і
своїх сімей
саме заради сім'ї деліє виїхала з
Парагваю щоб працювати інтерною 17 років
потому її власні діти стали для неї
практично чужими
Я б не зробила цього знову я б
залишилась у своїй країні і якось
подбала про своїх дітей там але
Принаймні я була б з ними сьогодні в
мене вже немає Надії повернути їхню
любов
Лілія все одно пишається тим що її
робота дозволила її дітям здобути освіту
але ціна яку довелося заплатити була
дуже високою
Контрнаступ України триває вже більше
двох місяців відвойовувати окуповані
Росією територій складне завдання
особливо навколо міста Бахмут
частина успіхів в українських військ у
протистоянні з росіянами зумовлена
зброєю яку можна взяти в одну руку
дронами вони стали головним елементом на
полі бою у цій війні ніколи раніше у
зонах конфліктів не використовувалося
стільки Дронів це зброя нової ери яка
змінює наше уявлення про війну
поблизу фронту солдати щосекунди
ризикують своїм життям вони повинні
працювати швидко поки їх не помітили
схоже на пластикову акулу але це
найважливіша зброя цього підрозділу на
сході України надсучасний розвідувальний
дрон
цей Дрон може пролетіти 40 кілометрів
глибоко втил російських військ Пілот і
другий Пілот знаходяться у
переобладнаному фургоні
Ну і треба буде треба буде підлетіти
ближче до того краю каже Юрій
він другий Пілот після того як виявили
кілька цілей вони передають Координати
Там є кілька вогневих позицій зараз Ми
визначаємо точне місцезнаходження цих
позицій і підтвердимо їхні координати
ось наша місія
дані про польоти строго засекречені Нам
навіть не дозволено знімати монітори ось
наскільки складна і тонка робота
розвідки і наскільки вона життєво
важлива каже командир Олександр
дрони так важливі бо зараз 90% втрат
ворога - Це втрата від артилерії а
ефективність артилерії це в першу чергу
коригування і розвідка пізніше ми
дізнаємося наскільки успішним був політ
дрона пілотом доводиться ухилятися від
Російської протиповітряної оборони і за
їхніми словами нерідко навіть від вогню
Своїх же насторожених військ
війна Дронів в Україні вийшла на
абсолютно Новий рівень
сьогодні дистанційно керовані дрони
несуть смерть страх і руйнування тисячам
людей і не лише на полі бою
українські міста систематично стають
цілями Дронів камікадзе
Москва також повідомляла про атаки
Дронів
це стало війною спеціалістів із озброєнь
як цивільних так і військових
тут у підвальній майстерні Без вікон у
Києві волонтери збирають базові маленькі
ударні дрони Багато з них піднімуться у
повітря лише один раз дрони камікадзе
вони прикріплюють зелені детонатори до
звичайних цивільних Дронів китайського
виробництва Антон керівник майстерні
показує як виготовляють детонатори за
допомогою автоматичних 3d-принтерів
це найбільш затратна по часу частина
друк може зайняти до 20 годин а може й
більше
Це залежить від деталей які ви друкуєте
зараз ви можете побачити тут деталі для
скидачів
принтери їм пожертвували але більшість
матеріалів вони купили самі розповідає
Антон це має фінансовий сенс Дрон за 400
євро може пошкодити танк вартістю у
мільйони але багато Дронів прослужить на
фронті Лише кілька днів тож попит на них
величезний ніхто не знає точно які
щоденні втрати але Антон каже що без
волонтерів вони б не впоралися
долучатися до цього приділяти більшу
уваги розуміти чому ці дрони важливі ми
працюємо тут як одна велика спільнота з
розробки Дронів
вони не кажуть скільки ударних Дронів
збирають тут щотижня лише підтверджують
що цього недостатньо
частину Дронів відправляють на цей
командний пункт під бахмутом
тут у режимі реального часу
відслідковуються приміти трансляції з
понад сотні літальних апаратів у тій
самій кімнаті де солдати сплять
Герман керує цими місіями він вирішує
коли йде ці саморобні дрони завдадуть
удару
це можна техніка давайте розуміти це не
військова техніка вона проста по суті
але це електроніка Раптом щось не
забіндилося чи ще щось якщо людина цього
не розуміє То все операція зірвана ніхто
нікуди не летить
у безпечному місці солдати демонструють
нам моделі Камікадзе як правило вони
скеровують начинені вибухівкою дрони
Прямо в ціль
для сьогоднішньої вправи вони прикріпили
до дрона муляж гранати керують ним за
допомогою відеоокулярів на які надходить
зображення у реальному часі
Герман вважає розвиток бойових Дронів
нової тенденцією нам треба постійно щось
міняти щоб це працювало
тому що на кожну дію є протидія і так
само і з нашого боку на кожну дію є
протидія якщо технологія не розвивається
то вона має дуже короткий термін життя
він прогнозує гонку озброєнь між
російськими та українськими інженерами у
короткостроковій перспективі але в
майбутньому Він впевнений що дрони
будуть виконувати більше місії у яких
його війська зараз ризикують життям
повертаємося на передову бійці кажуть що
розвідувальний політ пройшов добре
Пізніше вони надіслали нам це відео
сказавши що на ньому видно як Вони
виявили сховану російську артилерію
незабаром після цього мали відбутися
Атака чи можна уявити собі майбутнє
війни без Дронів
Я думаю що ні І якщо не треба будуть
ніде будуть ще війни в майбутньому вони
будуть тільки вже з дронами
в Україні дрони стали реальністю
анонімною дистанційно керованою
смертоносною реальністю
це дуже суперечливе питання як із
політичної так і соціальної точки зору
як утилізувати ядерні відходи де їх
можна безпечно зберігати Німеччина вже
відмовилась від ядерної енергетики Але
досі немає відповіді на ці питання інші
країни Європи досі значної мірою
покладаються на ядерну енергетику
Фінляндія одна з них але ця
скандинавська країна зуміла зробити те
чого не зробила жодна інша країна світу
вона будує перше у світі постійне
сховище ядерних відходів сховища вже
майже готове біля західного узбережжя на
острові олкілото
чверть мільйона тонн високо
радіоактивних ядерних відходів
зберігаються по всьому світу У деяких
випадках токсини просочуються у довкілля
але не у Фінляндії Фін і єдині у світі
будують постійне сховище для зберігання
високоактивних ядерних відходів усього
за три години їзди від столиці Гельсінки
у муніципалітеті під назвою еро айокі де
вже працює атомна електростанція це
місце називається онколо або фінською
печера
ми опускаємось на 430 метрів під землю
Анті юдсен головний Геолог компанії яка
відповідає за сховище цю ділянку обрали
через особливі умови
майже два мільярди років Вона досить
непорушна доволі суха тут практично
немає руху підземних вод
не набагато випереджають більшість націй
у тому числі
і тому 70% фінів позитивно ставляться до
ядерної енергетики
Ні я не боюся що станеться щось погане
вони дуже дбають про безпеку
Я думаю що це добре
держава отримує більше податків більше
грошей з цього більше робочих місць для
бізнесу це добре
щорічно еро айокі отримує близько 20
мільйонів європодатків на нерухомість
від ТІВІ оу компанія яка володіє атомною
електростанцією та місцем захоронені
відходів мені цепальний центр з
населенням у кілька тисяч мешканців має
власну поліклініку будинок для людей
похилого віку бібліотеку та багато
спортивних споруд і зараз будується ще
один спортивний центр вартість у 9 млн
євро веса я лоненко колишній учитель
живе тут уже понад 50 років
люди Фінляндії так думають бо це
дослідили інженери
наприклад Наш регулятор стук ми йому
дуже довіряємо насправді ми можемо
сказати що дуже пишаємося цим
для декого Це може бути дивним адже
високоактивніядерні відходи це
надзвичайні відходи а Вони складаються
переважно із відпрацьованих ядерних
паливних стрижнів і можуть залишатися
радіоактивними сотні тисяч років щоб
запобігти витоку радіоактивності зі
стрижнів на цей час вони мають бути
належним чином захищені у Фінляндії
відпрацьовані паливні стрижні
запечатують у мідні каністри товщиною 5
см і висотою близько 5 метрів потім їх
поміщають у свердловинні на глибині
понад 400 метрів під землею свердловину
засипають бентонітовою глиною яка може
поглинати ґрунтові води що можуть
просочуватись у середину і роз'їдати
мідні каністри
на завершення тунель заповнюють тим
самим матеріалом ми закривають бетонною
плитою завдовжки 6 метрів
це наш перший справжній тунель для
захоронення
його довжина 350 метрів
у ньому можна розмістити близько 40
капсул
Думки щодо того наскільки швидко мідні
каністри можуть піддаватися корозії
різняться але фінський орган з ядерної
безпеки каже що це не становитиме
значного ризику і що каністра це лише
один захисний шар із багатьох
ми розробили концепцію настільки
надійною що навіть якщо ми зробили якусь
хибну оцінку чи недооцінили якісь
процеси які можуть відбуватися у сховищі
ми маємо запас міцності у нашій
концепції
сховище буде поступово розширюватися і
заповнюватися протягом приблизно
століття його загальна довжина
становитиме 50 кілометрів а потім його
назавжди запечатають і більше не
чіпатимуть інші європейці протестують
проти постійного зберігання
високоактивних ядерних відходів у своїх
країнах чому
нічо існує взаємний консенсус що ми
повинні подбати про відходи не залишати
їх майбутнім поколінням
можливо саме тому фіни незабаром стануть
першими у світі хто візьметься за
постійне зберігання високоактивних
ядерних відходів
життя в європейських столицях коштує
недешево висока вартість проживання дуже
ускладнює життя сім'ям Уявіть собі що ви
йдете вранці на роботу і не зустрічайте
дітей які йдуть до школи практично саме
це відбувається в Лондонському районі
канден Лондон одне з найдорожчих місць
Європи і ціни на оренду житла в ньому
приголомшливо високі в результаті діти
зникають з міста
заняття закінчилися але чогось не
вистачає
замість галасу наприкінці дня У цій
Лондонській початковій школі незвично
тихо при повній завантаженості тут могло
б навчатися до 300 учнів але сьогодні їх
лише двоє
донедавна сюди ходив син Лізи з тенісом
Діас
Але перед Різдвом з'явилася новина що
влітку школу закриють
причиною закриття школи був не
добіручнів було недостатньо дітей які
подавали заявки недостатньо дітей які
приходили до школи за кілька тижнів
дітей майже не залишилося усі пішли в
інші школи
знайти нову школу для дія забула нелегко
сім'я живе у кандені в центрі Лондона де
чотири школи швидко закрили свої двері
через нестачу дітей
знаєте Він багато запитував чому мій
друг більше не ходить до школи і в яку
школу я піду А ви знаєте які це
переживання а в його віці Він не повинен
ні про що турбуватися
на щастя дія зміг отримати місце в іншій
школі неподалік
обідня перерва
але на дитячому майданчику панує
моторошна тиша жодної дитини не видно
такий феномен новий каже Ендрю дайєр
давній мешканець кандена
він працював тут учителем до того як
почав працювати у профспілці його район
змінився майже до невпізнання
спільноти робітничого класу у
багатодітній сім'ї вони були повсюди це
було місцем де хотілося виховувати дітей
Зараз таки бачиш все рідше і рідше і не
треба далеко ходити щоб зрозуміти чому
житло в Лондоні не помірно дороге
будинок обійдеться вам майже О два
мільйони євро трикімнатна квартира у 690
тисяч
сім'ї просто більше не можуть дозволити
собі жити тут ринок оренди не менш
жорсткий чотирикімнатна квартира може
легко коштувати до 4 тисяч євро на
місяць
Я боюся що дуже скоро канден
перетвориться на район де живуть багатії
і люди похилого віку і втратить свою
душу
і це стосується не лише камдена але й
всього Лондона скрізь з'являються нові
будівлі але дуже мало з них призначені
для сімей у цій новобудові буде багато
невеликих квартир розрахованих для
заможних подружніх пар
Еліс Браун філберг архітекторка вона
стурбована останніми подіями і тим як
вони змінять обличчя міста Я думаю що
найважливіше те що ми повинні створювати
простори і будівлі які допомагають
формувати змішані і різноманітні
спільноти і нам потрібен хороший баланс
у всьому Ох ні на сході Лондона батьки
та діти влаштували акцію протесту біля
місцевої мерії їхній школі теж загрожує
закриттям що змусить багато сімей
виїхати з цього району без школи вони не
можуть тут залишатися нам напевно
доведеться переїхати з району Це було б
неймовірно сумно Ми живемо тут вже
більше 15 років ми любимо це місце наші
діти люблять його
а закриття майже неминуче але місцеві
мешканці не здадуться без бою
Я не знаю як виглядатиме місто якщо в
ньому не буде дітей якщо в ньому не буде
сімей
я не можу собі уявити яким би воно було
але думаю що це було б сумним бездушне
місце
Лондон
його заступники з питань житлового
будівництва Але можливо саме До цього
все і йде Це безумовно проблема саме
тому ми відчайдушно потребуємо більше
фінансування від уряду щоб мати змогу
будувати доступне житло ми робимо все
можливе з мерії з тим повноваженнями і
фінансуванням які має міський голова але
цього просто недостатньо
і збільшення фінансування мало ймовірне
тожниця порожні дитячі майданчики
Лондона залишатимуться похмурою
метафорою майбутнього цього міста
значна частина Неаполя контролюється
каморою злочинної організації що у
родини півдні Італії це одна з
найвідоміших мафій в країні яка протягом
10 літ займається наркоторгівлею
ці злочинні угрупування дуже активні в
районі Сан Джованні те дутча
але зараз дається Все змінюється
технології допомоги там де ви можливо не
очікували цього у районах де роками
панувала бідність студенти та
перепрацюють над розробкою додатків
неподалік від везувію знаходиться район
сан-джування
довгий час він вважався неблагополучним
районом Неаполя але останніми роками
ситуація покращилася для іларії сауліно
Все також змінилося на краще Вона
навчається у новому університетському
кампусі дівчина бачила як змінювався цей
район з плином часу
[музика]
найбільша в сан-джованні змінилося те що
мешканці звикли до студентів навколо
університету відкрилося багато невеликих
магазинів і закладів що полегшило нам
життя район ожив завдяки молоді
Цей район Неаполя довгий час був місцем
бідності безробіття та потужного впливу
мафії
але те що колись було занедбаним
промисловим об'єктом зараз стало
передовим університетським кампусом
і Саме тут в університеті Федеріко II за
підтримки ЄС стартувала перша програма
академія розробників Apple
тепер студенти з усього світу вчаться
тут як розробляти програмне забезпечення
для додатків і як створювати стартапи
Ілларія розробляє додаток для
відстеження нічних снів
Ми хочемо допомогти людям записувати
свої сни
протягом ночі додаток збирає дані
Наступного дня користувачі зможуть
проаналізувати свої сновидіння і
дізнатися як покращити свій сон
інша студентка Джулія вважає що додатки
можуть сприяти соціальним змінам це
стосується і санжування атю
успішний додаток це додаток який вирішує
проблеми у Неаполі щодня відбувається 6
арештів за насильство над жінками
[музика]
Джулія хоче допомогти жертвам домашнього
насильства
вона знає що часто саме фінансова
залежність заважає жертвам розлучитися
зі своїми агресивними партнерами
Пийте додаток який допоможе змінити
ситуацію на краще
наша мета створюється додаток який
допоможе жінкам стати більш фінансово
незалежними завдяки кращому управлінню
своїми фінансовими ресурсами
тим часом кілька технологічних компаній
відкрили свої офіси у цьому районі а
неаполітанський університет уже будує
додатковий корпус на території кампусу
Відродження триває
А на сьогодні це все Бережіть себе і до
зустрічі за тиждень у новому випуску
Європа У фокусі
[музика]